hey 42 here a study by Stanford
University revealed that in the US alone
3.5 million children and teenagers are
injured playing sports each year but
that figure is far greater in other
parts of the world where things are a
little less regulated and sports tend to
get a lot more messy here's the world's
top 10 most dangerous sports first up is
bull running known as the Running of the
Bulls or an thieriot this insane
sport usually takes place down the
quaint peaceful and extremely narrow
back streets of towns and cities all
across Spain before the bull run
commences a large crowd of people
gathers along a narrow back streets then
an angry herd of stampeding bulls is let
loose at one end of the street and
charges down it mowing down any
adrenaline pump Spaniard with a death
wish who happens to get in their way the
participants run in front of the Bulls
and the goal of the sport is to
basically avoid receiving a nasty
bludgeoning of Bulls horn where the Sun
don't shine the most popular bull one
happens every year in Pamplona in
northern Spain every year around 300
brave amigos are injured at the event
mostly due to contusions from being
knocked over since 1910 14 people have
been killed during camp loaners Running
of the Bulls imagine if someone told you
that they like to lie flat on a wooden
board with wheels on it and go hurtling
down a steep road with only their feet
to users brakes you would probably think
they're two trucks short of a skateboard
well a surprising amount of people
actually enjoy risking their lives doing
just that it's a sport known as street
luge and is similar to skateboarding
except the board is slightly longer and
the rider is required to be in a supine
position on their luge board which
basically means lying down face up oh
and to top it all off participants of
the sport sometimes go down public roads
with actual cars on them now when you
consider that the riders visual profile
is only a few inches from the road
surface you can probably imagine the
enormous risks involved if you think
that scary it gets worse
Street leaders can reach speeds of up to
97 miles per hour that's considerably
faster than a car traveling on a freeway
or motorway because the riders own legs
and feet are the only thing that they
can use as brakes broken legs or torn
ligaments are common in Street luging as
well as other more serious injuries next
up is the Vietnamese sport of high fat
it's a tradition in the village of Hyang
Kwan north of Hanoi each year thousands
of villagers gather on a Sun June and
fight over a painted red ball using
sticks
if it sounds primitively violent that's
because it is the villagers believe that
the ball will bring them good luck in
the new year
if they don't get their front teeth
knocked out trying to retrieve it at
first glance it may seem awfully similar
to hockey but there are two major
differences the sticks are considerably
cruder and more substantial and it's a
hell of a lot more violent the
participants are allowed to swing their
huge lumps of curved wards at anything
or anyone who gets in the way of the
ball
needless to say injuries are common and
blood is frequently spilt funny how
hitting people with sticks is not OK but
had a ball and hey suddenly it's a sport
if he fought hitting people with sticks
sounds violent how about hitting people
with sticks whilst hurling balls at them
that's pretty much the idea behind
lacrosse lacrosse is similar to football
or basketball but with long sticks with
nets on the end oh and there's an awful
lot more contact and general violent
tendencies between players lacrosse
isn't a commonly played sport because it
takes it tough and fearless individual
to play it at a competitive level when
it comes to rough contact the rules are
more relaxed with lacrosse than other
sports players are permitted to hit and
tackle the opponent's with sunken
durable force that will be illegal in
most other contact sports broken bones
punctured lungs and other serious
injuries are highly common in lacrosse
very similar to lacrosse is a sport
called irish hurling which is like
lacrosse but with ax shaped wooden
sticks minimal padding for the players
and it's considerably faster in fact it
is officially the world's fastest field
sport enough to make a lacrosse player
shake in their shin guards
now this next sport involves a bunch of
eccentric cheese lovers you've all had a
bit too much better for their own good
hurling themselves down a nearly
vertical Hill in pursuit of a wheel of
cheese it may sound a bit a mental but
it's a real sport and it's called
cheese rolling it takes place every year
in Gloucester England so what's the
point of all this surely there's enough
cheese in Gloucester to go around well
apparently not
the lucky winner that's the person who
can chuck their limp bodies down the
hill the fastest gets to keep the wheel
of cheese
but you can have too much of a Gouda
thing ok that's enough of the cheese
jokes but in all seriousness broken arms
and legs so extremely common place
during a cheese rolling event it may
look like fun but next time you're
thinking of throwing your body down a
hill after a wheel of cheese remember
it's a good deal safer to just go out
and buy one for a long time people would
look up to skydivers calling them
Daredevils or brave pioneers but then in
1978 some daring psychopath went in
jumped straight up a cliff wearing
nothing but a tracksuit and a small
parachute on their back and made all the
other Daredevils look a bit silly that
daring man was called carl boenish and
he was the catalyst for a new breed of
sport known as BASE jumping a sport
which is growing rapidly in popularity
and involves parachuting from any fixed
structure the name BASE jumping is an
acronym that stands for the four
categories of fixed objects which base
jumpers regularly throw themselves off
building antennae span and
earth that last one doesn't literally
involve hurling oneself off the face of
the earth in base-jumping earth refers
to cliffs as you can probably imagine
this sport is fraught with danger and
fatalities are common since the sport
started there have been over 250
recorded deaths from BASE jumping when
BASE jumping technical precision and
solid planning is essential to staying
alive the slightest mistake such as
steering in the wrong direction for a
second or even a strong gust of wind or
if you simply pull your parachute open a
second too late you will die this is not
for the faint-hearted next up is Buzz
Kashi literally meaning goats grabbing
this sport is played in Central Asia
particularly in Afghanistan where it is
actually the national sport it was
brought to Afghanistan by Genghis Khan's
Mongol hordes 800 years ago
buzz Kashi is quite simple all you need
to play is a pony and a dead goat oh and
20 fearless Afghan EES who aren't afraid
to get seriously hurt the goal that was
cutter issue fight over the goat carcass
called a boss and drag it towards a goal
games are long and can sometimes last
for several days but they are also as
brutal as they are long there are few
rules and plays hit opponents often and
hard to train dismount them or get the
goat carcass from them players are
usually equipped with whips which they
not only use on their own horse but the
opponent's horses and the opponents
themselves it's an extremely brutal
sport but it's not just two players like
gets injured on a regular basis busca
she games often attract crowd in their
thousands and spectators are ratters mut
risk as the players are themselves
several times a game you can expect
players to be flown from their horses
and their horses to go careering to the
ground often into the crowd
spectators therefore have to be
constantly on their guard to avoid being
flattened or trampled on by a horse or
knocked out by a flying player there's
no dim
eyeing that American football is a
dangerous sport any sport where you have
to wear a helmet is sure to end in
catastrophe since 1931 there have been
1027 recorded deaths from American
football mostly due to catastrophic
brain injuries from players smacking
their helmets into one another but
American football is not quite as
dangerous as a sports which it came from
rugby imagine American football without
the hard helmets face masks shoulder
pads and basically every other form of
protection rugby players typically wear
little or no padding and any form of
hard protective gear is banned rugby is
a rough contact sport and to participate
you pretty much have to be built like a
tank
so if you're no wider than a plank of
wood expect to get knocked into the dirt
often and painfully especially when
you're up against this loss the two
leading causes of death in rugby
are concussion and drowning no it's not
played underwater but unfortunately
players can sometimes drown in the mud
if they're trapped face down at the
bottom of a pileup which in rugby is
called a rock next up is boxing there's
no prize for guessing why boxing is
dangerous boxing basically consists of
50% getting hit in the face by a
well-trained killing machine and the
other 50% trying not to get hit in the
face obviously it's a brutal sport but
just how dangerous is it well a
professional boxer can punch with up to
1,400 pounds per square inch of pressure
that's enough power to accelerate their
opponents head at a rate of 53 g that's
53 times the force of gravity a punch
with that much force can cause all sorts
of issues such as detached retinas brain
hemorrhages fractured skulls and
permanent neurological disorders such as
dementia between 1918 and 1997 there
were at least 650 recorded deaths from
professional boxing and finally is horse
bike riding but surely beating people
with sticks or jumping off buildings is
more dangerous than horseback riding
well no it may come as a surprise but
riding a horse is probably the most
dangerous sport you can possibly do
horseback riding is not just about
little men jumping over wooden blocks
and occasionally going flying into a
muddy puddle there's a lot more to
equestrianism than meets the eye just
staying on top of a horse is a difficult
task in itself contrary to popular
belief you can't use your hands or legs
to balance on a horse because the rider
uses those to communicate with the horse
so you have to balance on top of a 550
kilogram animal traveling at speeds of
up to 70 kilometres per hour using only
your buttocks to balance statistics say
that every horse rider can expect a
serious injury for every 350 hours of
riding but it's not just a high
frequency of injuries that makes it
dangerous it's the seriousness of those
injuries which is truly shocking
horseback riders can have their spinal
cord snapped cleanly in two from a fall
or their skulls crushed onto a horse's
hoof and that's just whilst riding the
horse horses can be unpredictable and
whilst they're not riding them riders
face two constant threat of being kicked
by a horse without warning a horse's
kick can exert up to 2,000 pounds of
pressure per square inch
in fact horses have been known to kick
holes in stable walls with minimal
effort horseback riding can be dangerous
for the horses too if a horse sustains
an injury whilst racing such as a broken
leg because horses are extremely
expensive animals to maintain the
injured horse is usually euthanized
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you